hey friends
i was just teaching a guitar lesson and
i heard this loud bang
and i realized i have broken another
string
so i've had a pretty unlucky two weeks
here
and i was about to cut it off uh and
then i realized oh wait
i can save this string and i was about
to do it but then i realized you know
what i'm gonna wait
and film this because i think this is a
really great
tip to know for all the guitarists out
there that will really get you out of a
pickle
if you maybe don't have an extra string
on hand before a
recording session or maybe you're about
to walk out on stage
so this is how to salvage a broken
string
now a few weeks ago i broke a string as
well and i made a video
with a couple tips on how to stop
breaking strings
that string broke in a very different
way it was my b string and that was made
of gut
a bit more prone to breaking and that
broke at the nut and i realized it was
because maybe the nut slot was a bit too
thin it couldn't really fit the string
and the string was grinding against
the nut slot and eventually it snapped
this is a very different break and it
could be a very different tip
as a result here i'm using nylon strings
on the cedar top guitar by says guitars
and the nylon string um bass strings
on classical guitars are basically a
silk core a bunch of silk threads
wrapped with some type of metal and
this break happened right at the the
bridge
basically the winding is still attached
but the most of the string popped popped
up and i can actually see the
i can feel the inside of the silk now
but it looks pretty bad
the strings flopping all over the place
and if i was less experienced at this
point i would say oh
i just have to cut off the string and
find a new one and undo this one and it
would take a long time
and what if i didn't have an extra
string and i had to go on stage
i would be seriously in a pickle so two
things you always need in your guitar
case
you need a nail clippers or something to
cut strings
and you need a peg winder this is
optional the peg winder but it really
speeds up the process especially if
you're about to walk on stage maybe
you're in the middle of a concert
and by the way what i'm going to show
you here applies to
all instruments that use wound strings
around some type of
core material so this works for all
types of guitars electric basses
oods loots that use metal bound strings
so to salvage this broken string what
we're going to do is we're going to
find where it sort of sort of unwound
and we're going to cut as close as we
can
to salvage as much of the string as
possible i don't want to you know cut in
the middle we're going to try to save
this thing
so i'm going to cut it just enough so
that i have a
clean uh wound string there's no like
frailing off of the end
and now i'm left with this you know
string
tied to the bridge of course which we
can just get rid of you can just rip
this off
there and again you can you can see
where the
silk came loose there okay so now we
grab this
long string that's tied to the headstock
uh and we're basically going to kind of
pull this down and we're going to re-tie
it
and then that's it so this is like a
two-minute fix if you do it right
however for this to work you have to
make sure that
when you tie your strings on you don't
cut off all the excess
string on all my instruments i tie the
strings at the bridge
i clip off the excess but then i wind as
much of the string as possible
uh inside the scroll inside the
headstock
that way when the string does break at
the bridge i can pull it down and i have
a lot of excess
string if you clip all the excess off
you can't do this trick
okay so all i need to do now is
gradually loosen
the string here and i'll get more and
more
length out of it and once i have
enough i can tie it at the bridge
i still have quite a lot of string so
this is this is good news
now while i'm doing that i just wanted
to mention if you're enjoying this
guitar tip and you want to see
more tips like this you can head over to
my patreon page where i have lots of
exclusive tips and behind-the-scenes
content
where you can sign up and get instant
access to all of that
there's also mp3 downloads of my videos
cds and you can even get
a one-on-one lesson with me on skype so
check that out
for now back to the video now this is
taking a little bit long so this is
where i can grab my
my peg winder let's say the audience is
waiting
hold on guys and then just keep bringing
this all the way down
and if i can get it so that the nod is
still there so i still have tension
that's even faster
if i have to i can just put it back
through the slot and
and re-tie okay so we keep loosening
until
we have some string that goes quite a
bit past the bridge
right so if we can get like two inches
past the bridge we should have enough
to tie it around um sometimes you just
don't make it you were so close and
that's that's a tragedy but
so i have enough string now i'm going to
simply put it through the
slot straight through with the extra
string kind of taut to get as much
length as possible on the bridge side
now we wrap it underneath itself
[Music]
like so and now we put it back
underneath itself and depending on the
string you might want to go back
again underneath itself one more time
there okay and now we pull a bit to have
have a bit of a knot to stop the string
and actually here's where some people
make a mistake
um they leave the excess string the exit
point
on top of the bridge uh this is not good
this is not very secure what you want
is for the last part of the string that
leaves the knot
to be on the underside of the bridge so
pull that string around
and see if you can get it on the back
side of the bridge
and that will be a much stronger hold
and now we can actually just give the
string a couple
yanks to get it taut that string's not
going anywhere
which means now we can grab our peg
winder start winding attach the string
[Music]
i first usually tune it up until it
sounds like
the e so now i've at a checkpoint i
still have a ways to go
and i usually use my you know my ear
training
uh here comes the bride here comes the
bride
[Music]
is a perfect fourth which means this
should now
be an a and i did it
so i know that was a long explanation
but to actually do that
takes maybe a minute or two on stage so
next time you're about to cut off a
string and throw it away
double check that you can salvage it
first
and get back to play see you next time
you